hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen so we're gonna be talking
a lot about intuitive eating over the
next few months but before we get like
too far into it I really wanted to cover
a topic that I get asked about a lot and
that is the idea of food addiction now
before we get into the research and let
me tell ya I had to put my full lab coat
on for this one I just want to say that
I have tremendous empathy for those II
who are struggling with the feelings of
food addiction I know that a lot of you
would describe feeling out of control of
certain foods and you can only describe
it kind of like some kind of addictive
experience with food and I know that it
often feels like you need some kind of
abstinence in order to maintain a sense
of control I am not discounting your
lived experience I know that it is so
real for so many of you however I
definitely want to give you some tools
and some guidance that is informed by
the literature hey everyone Switzerland
here I want to just chime in and
acknowledge that I know that some of
this guidance or these tools may not be
tailored or suited for all of you
you know I've tried to be really
unbiased and open-minded in my analysis
of this even more so after my little
epiphany here
but I do recognize that ultimately this
may not perfectly encompass your unique
experience so take what you can from it
and just know that the answer for you
might be completely different and that's
why I always recommend working
one-on-one with a registered dietician
when you can so first of all what is
addiction now according to the Society
of addiction management addiction is a
primary chronic disease of brain reward
motivation memory and related circuitry
essentially it's a change in the brain
that results in a person continuously
seeking at reward or relief from a
certain substance like drugs or a
certain behavior like sex
so addiction is diagnosed using a very
friendly mnemonic ABCDE
an inability to consistently abstain
impairment of behavioral control craving
or increased hunger for drugs or
rewarding and experiences diminished
recognition of significant problems with
one's behaviors or interpersonal
relationships and a dysfunctional
emotional response
furthermore the decent criteria for
substance abuse disorder also includes
spending a lot of time finding and
seeking out and using the substance an
inability to cut back on using it
despite trying to and continuing to use
the substance even though they or others
know it's harmful
finally addiction usually includes some
kind of cycle of relapse and remission
so then what is food addiction so the
theory for food addiction involves a lot
of the same criteria as traditional
addiction it would suggest that people
with a food addiction have an inability
to abstain from certain foods crave them
and cannot control their intake of them
so the idea of food addiction can be
partially related and attributed to the
Yale food addiction skill which is a
self reporting tool used to measure kind
of addictive like habits related to food
it has 35 questions related to certain
eating behaviors and is based off of the
DSM criteria for substance abuse it also
asks if the person has significant
distress in relation to food so once
completed answers that meet the criteria
for 11 different addictive behaviors
related to food are tallied and if a
person has three or more of these
behaviors plus they experience some kind
of significant distress related to food
they are diagnosed with a food addiction
while the Yale food addiction scale may
be useful in some settings it doesn't
really tell us that much the scale is
ultimately based on people's experience
not actual data about addiction so it
really only tells us about people's
perceptions and feelings
it also doesn't include any questions
related to dieting or restriction so
when a person is diagnosed with a food
addiction they aren't even screened for
an eating disorder
despite time and time again research
showing that these things are heavily
correlated that is a problem so we don't
actually know whether or not it's
measuring anything that is different
than an eating disorder meanwhile one
side that used the Yale Addiction scale
found that a persistent desire or
repeated and unsuccessful attempts to
quit a particular food was the only
characteristic of food addiction that
was commonly found in other words the
other common characteristics of
addiction were not common in relation to
food even if this tool is not perfect
there are tons of other reasons why this
concept of food addiction prevails so
let's dig into the
okay so let's talk about first of all
the dopamine response to food now
dopamine is one of the major
neurotransmitters that are released from
the brain when somebody does drugs
so from smoking a cigarette to injecting
heroin dopamine levels rise one of the
big arguments for the idea that food is
an addictive substance is based on
research that have shown that we have a
dopamine response from food that is
similar to our dopamine response from
drugs in a small human study researchers
gave participants either a tasty
milkshake or a tasteless solution and
their brains were analyzed the
researchers have found that in the
participants who had the tasty milkshake
they saw a dopamine response at two
times first when the milkshake was
consumed and second when that food
entered into the stomach so this
dopamine release occurs in the dorsal
stratum part of the brain and it's the
same part of the brain that releases
dopamine when somebody does cocaine now
let's talk about rats now in a very
famous 2005 study three groups of rats
were given a sugar solution one group
was given the sugar solution for 12
hours the other group was given it twice
and the other group was given it ad
libitum which basically means they could
have it whenever they wanted so
researchers then looked at the rats
brains and found that on the first day
all the rats released dopamine now this
is of course to be expected because we
always release dopamine in response to a
new novel food just so that our body can
kind of keep tabs on it in case it turns
out to be like poison or something so
basically your brain is kind of on high
alert to new foods interestingly the
rats were only given that sugar for 12
hours a day binge on that sugar and
their dopamine levels continue to rise
over the course of a month as they
needed to eat more and more and more of
that sugar in those 12 hours the rats
who are given free rein on the sugar did
not demonstrate bench like tendencies
which I'll talk about more later and
after day one their dopamine levels
actually stabilized in other words it
was the binge like tendencies that
produce a dopamine response similar to
what we see with hard drugs next let's
talk about withdrawal symptoms so
another big reason why people really buy
into the idea of food addiction is
because of the research on withdrawal
evidence from grad studies have found
that when rats are used to eating sugar
and then somebody takes that away from
them they experience a lot of withdrawal
like symptoms like anxiety depression
changes in blood pressure and heart rate
when researchers looked at the brains of
these rats experiencing withdrawal they
found that their dopamine levels had
dropped which is also something that we
would see in a person experiencing
withdrawal from hard drugs they also
noted a rise in the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine which is also something
that we would see in people who are
experiencing withdrawal from drugs and
finally let's talk about the behavioral
response when we compare sugar versus
healthy foods the other major argument
about why food and particularly sugar is
unique in its addictive like qualities
comes from that 2005 study that we
already discussed so they gave the rats
the healthy food intermittently so for
12 hours but they did not find that the
rats binge in the first hour and they
did not increase their intake of the
healthy food over time since the
opposite was found when the rats were
given sugar intermittently the argument
was made that there's something
inherently unique about sugar that
really makes it difficult not to want to
binge on now this all sounds really
convincing but let's first consider that
a lot of these days were largely rodent
based and we can also be this from the
opposing side now let's look at some of
the research critiquing the idea of food
addiction first let's talk about the
dopamine response so in contrast to some
of the research I mentioned earlier a
full review at the literature in 2014
found no evidence that the brain reacts
the same way to sugar and cocaine and
that sugar does not have the same neural
hijacking on the brain that cocaine does
what actually may be a more accurate
description of the relationship is that
we have these pleasure centers in the
brain that are firing when we eat and
that's a very natural normal reaction
but actually that drugs are hijacking
these natural pathways now in addition
to addictive substances like cocaine we
also see the same don't mean like
response to non-addictive stimuli and
behaviors like holding your baby humor
music laughing seeing somebody that you
love smiling etc arguably music and
humor are not addictive neither is
smiling but they are pleasurable much
like food so based on that our
meant to call sugar or any food
addictive you'd also have to call
cuddling your baby addictive or buying a
loved one a gift addictive okay so then
argument to this is a normal
evolutionary response evolutionarily it
only makes sense for us to derive some
pleasure from food otherwise we would
have no drive to obtain it in dangerous
circumstances and ultimately we wouldn't
survive our brains are designed to make
certain things rewarding like mating or
eating in order to prolong our species
specifically when it comes to sugar our
bodies really depend on it at least from
an evolutionary perspective as the
preferred source of fuel and energy in
the body furthermore in one of the
studies that I mentioned previously they
found that people had a harder time
managing high sugar and high-fat foods
this makes total sense from an
evolutionary perspective fat is the most
calorie dense kind of macronutrient so
we get the most energy for the smallest
package and sugar is immediately
absorbed into the bloodstream so we get
fast energy so if a food is calorie
dense and has immediate energy it makes
total sense that our body is going to
want to choose that over other kinds of
foods now in periods of deprivation and
starvation our body works in overdrive
to kind of force us to eat this can
result in sending extreme hunger cues
which can lead to binging like tenancies
well a lot of people may see this as
kind of relapsing or giving into your
sugar addiction this is actually just a
deep-seated biological survival
mechanism you didn't fail yourself by
not pushing through your craving this is
completely natural and a healthy
response to deprivation what's more is
that your body is really really smart
it's going to look for the best easiest
option available with the least amount
of energy required to get it so what
does that mean sugar of course because
sugar is easily absorbed into the
bloodstream with little to no digestion
required this just makes biological
sense and that brings me to the argument
around restriction now back to that
research looking at rats and relating
sugar to cocaine now despite seeing an
initial dopamine response to sugar which
we talked about was totally normal based
on any kind of novel food the
researchers are only found these
addictive like behaviors and dopamine
response in the rats who had their show
restricted from them and who were then
stressed out about that restriction that
means that when rats were able to have
sugar whenever they desired their brains
did not light up the same way that they
would to opioids in fact they responded
just as they would to any other kind of
food the authors say it beautifully
intermittent access is critical to the
development of binging this paradigm
promotes a form of eating under
uncertainty because food availability is
unpredictable so this was also seeing
that older study with binging rats so
the rats that were given sugar access
for just 12 hours of the day binge on
that sugar and then after 21 days their
sugar intake gradually increased
meanwhile the rest that were given
access to sugar whenever they wanted did
not binge and therefore their total
sugar intake was actually lower and even
though we didn't see that same desire to
binge with healthy foods suggesting that
there may be something unique about
sugar which makes sense given the
biological things we just talked about
in evolution I do think that this binge
like 10 C can be mitigated simply by
removing the novel or off-limits factor
here this is exactly why I hate the idea
of cheat days but that of course is rats
so let's talk about how things work in
humans now research suggests that people
who feel that they have a food addiction
tend to have a long complicated history
with food addiction and dieting so when
we finally allow ourselves to eat that
forbidden food our brains get excited
and we can't help but binge and feel out
of control research has found that
people who have restricted certain foods
for long periods of time actually react
differently in the brain to certain food
cues and the researchers found that this
may actually lead to a greater desire to
obtain those foods reaches in the brain
affiliated with for moretz were also
more active suggesting for these people
these restricted foods actually had to
become rewards the result is that these
foods become desirable which may lead to
overeating and the perception of feeling
out of control furthermore if we learn
anything from diet culture it's that
when we restrict food we are way more
likely to kind of binge on these
forbidden foods in our eyes these foods
become so special so novel it's
virtually impossible to not overdo it on
them so this sugar addiction or food
addiction actually exists we don't
really know
and while we don't know whether or not
sugar addiction is technically real
there's really no denying that it often
feels overwhelmingly real to you and
ultimately I think that's what really
matters so what are the next steps how
can we move past these feelings of sugar
addiction well when a person's try to
recover from an addiction it usually
involves complete abstinence of the
substance or behavior for food addiction
this would mean abstaining from the
problem foods such as those that are
high in sugar or fat the problem is this
is basically a diet in disguise and
could be detrimental to somebody who is
suffering from disordered eating in fact
it's probably going to exacerbate all
the bench like tendencies as all of the
evidence I say that suggests one study
found that ninety six percent of people
with self-reported bulimia met the
criteria for food addiction while only
14 percent without an eating disorder
met the criteria for food addiction this
was also found in another study that
suggested that 30 percent of people who
met the criteria for the Yale food
addiction scale also met the criteria
for binge eating disorder coincidence I
think not generally speaking when we're
treating an eating disorder or even sort
of behaviors we're looking at
normalizing all foods rather than
eliminating foods as the research
clearly suggests to completely eliminate
these certain foods from your diet will
very likely exacerbate the problem this
just highlights how different the
treatment paths needs to be for
something like the feelings of food
addiction compared to traditional
addiction okay so I want to chime in
here and address those of you who feel
completely addicted to sugar but who do
not meet the criteria for an eating
disorder so you might be asking yourself
or asking me a B is abstinence the only
answer I also think it's totally
reasonable that if something makes you
feel out of control or unhealthy or a
you know uncomfortable that you feel
like you need to limit exposure until
you can get those feelings under control
however I do still believe that the long
term solution is not to just never look
at a cupcake again because you know hey
cupcakes happen and you want to be in a
better headspace for when they do
honestly from a professional opinion I
would say that we just do not have any
strong research to make any conclusive
recommendations across the board all I
know is that this is a highly individual
thing and for that reason my
recommendation would be to really reach
out and try to get a really good
therapist and dietitian team to help you
work through some of these feelings that
would be my professional recommendation
as always my job is to give an unbiased
look at the literature and the research
and help you unpack that what you take
away from that is completely
personalized and up to you I will also
be sharing more insights and information
on intuitive eating in the months to
come in my intuitive eating series so I
definitely encourage you to follow along
but by all means this is not meant to be
a comprehensive treatment or plan I'm
gonna leave some links below if this is
sounding a bit like your story so guys I
hope you enjoyed this if you did be sure
to give it a thumbs up leave me a
comment below with any of your questions
don't forget we're gonna be covering a
lot of this in the intuitive eating
series and of course subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]